[Music]
we have the answer to the question of
whether Prince Harry and Megan will
attend next month's coronation if King
Charles says you know it's dominated the
discussion ever since the date was set
in May finally we've got an answer today
he is going she is not MTS tayab is
outside Buckingham Palace where the
announcement was made yesterday MTS it's
been a big should they will they could
they and now we know good morning to you
Gail good morning to you too yeah the
British press has just been breathless
in their speculation of will they or
won't they well we finally have an
answer and it came in the form of a very
brief two-sentence statement from here
Buckingham Palace
[Music]
the statement reads the Duke of Sussex
will attend the coronation service at
Westminster Abbey on May 6. the Duchess
of Sussex will remain in California with
Prince Archie and Princess lilibit a
compromise it seems for the new king
says Sunday Times Royal editor Roy Anika
I think Harry coming home is on his own
was the Hope from many inside the palace
because the focus will be much more on
the king and the Queen on Coronation Day
as it should be rather than on what side
show might be going on with Harry and
Megan in attendance Prince Harry hasn't
been in the UK much since he and Megan
step back as working Royals in 2020. he
attended Prince Phillips's funeral and
the couple returned when Queen Elizabeth
died
Prince Harry was also here last month to
attend a high court hearing in his case
against the Publishers of a British
tabloid newspaper but while promoting
his best-selling bombshell Memoir spare
he told 60 Minutes as Anderson Cooper in
January he wanted to sit down with
members of his family to discuss the
issues he's been so open about privately
there needs to be a construction of
conversation one that can happen in
private that doesn't get late it's not
clear if that conversation happened nor
do we know how or why the decision was
made he would attend the coronation
alongside two thousand other guests
including the first lady and not his
wife and children whatever the reason
this will be the first time Prince Harry
will be seen in public with King Charles
the queen consort Camilla and Prince
William since writing so unsparingly
about them in his book including of the
physical fight with his brother and how
both of them begged their father not to
marry Camilla
as for Megan well the coronation happens
to fall on Prince Archie's fourth
birthday but her absence on the king's
crowning moment well it's only going to
add fuel to the speculation that this
Royal Rift is deeper than ever Gail
MTS tie up reporting from Buckingham
Palace we thank you it's like all
families have a little bit of drama I'm
glad the decision has been made all the
speculation I'm glad they've decided and
made the decision that I I think they
feel is best for them it's good that
Harry's going oh I think it is
if they haven't had that private
conversation that healing conversation I
hope they do while he's there yes yes
yes I hope so too